spagat zwischen hongkong krise und
wirtschaftsdienst warum merkels mission
in peking so heikel ist symbolpolitik
oder wirksamer umweltschutz wie die
umweltministerin plastiktüten verbieten
will
neues aus der welt der technik was
durchsichtige fernseher und faltbare
smartphones alles können zeigt die ifa
in berlin
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers in schönen guten abend
wünsche ich ihnen an diesem freitag
heute um 7 ihr nachrichtenüberblick den
sport hat norbert lehmann im auge ein
schwimmender antwort von mir eine reise
nach china ist immer ein spagat für
deutsche regierungschefs aktuell ganz
besonders angela merkel hat eine große
firmen delegation mit dabei in peking
die auf neue geschäfte hofft mit dem
riesenmarkt china dessen führung auf
kritik empfindlich reagiert gleichzeitig
setzt sich die bundeskanzlerin für die
rechte und freiheiten wie sie sagt der
menschen in hongkong ein
china ist deutschlands wichtigster
handelspartner es geht um waren mit
einem wert von 199 milliarden euro
zahlen von 2008 zehnter auch dieses mal
hat die wirtschaft elf neue
vereinbarungen mit chinesischen partnern
geschlossen
die unruhen in hongkong seit monaten die
proteste der demokratiebewegung dort
machen den besuch für merkel zum
drahtseilakt sie hat das thema
angesprochen
zum ersten mal musste ich ihn als
ministerpräsident sich öffentlich dazu
äußern stephanie schöneborn aus peking
der besuch der kanzlerin in china sieht
aus wie immer und doch ist es diesmal
anders
schwieriger ist es schon allein zu
berichten
zuerst sollten in peking ansässige
deutsche journalisten von wichtigen
pressetermin ausgeschlossen werden dann
werden doch ein paar zugelassen
eigentlich wollte die kanzlerin vor
allem über die öffnung der märkte
sprechen
probleme durch den handelskrieg und neue
investitionsabkommen doch dann kann eine
pressekonferenz und die frage nach
hongkong
sie haben jetzt ein stichwort nicht
erwähnt haben sie über die spannung in
hongkong gesprochen haben sie eine
zusicherung bekommen dass china das
britisch chinesischen abkommen von 1984
ein held ich habe darauf hingewiesen
dass diese rechte und freiheiten
natürlich auch gewährleistet werden
müssen dieses abkommen gilt weiter und
es eröffnet eine ganze reihe von
bürgerlichen freiheiten die auch in
anspruch genommen werden können müssen
außerdem plädiert sie für dialog und
eine friedliche lösung in hongkong der
chinesische premier li qiang wird
wiederum danach gefragt ob china eine
militärische lösung ausschließe und es
sichtlich empört
wir befolgen das gesetz rief um das
chaos und die unordnung zu beenden
alles geschieht im rahmen des gesetzes
glauben sie
china ist dazu in der lage und china hat
nur weisheit sich um seine eigenen
angelegenheiten zu kümmern
danke damit war die pressekonferenz
beendet
bei dem spitzentreffen zwischen merkel
und dem chinesischen präsidenten jean
ping hat die presse wieder nur begrenzt
zutritt es ist eine schwierige
atmosphäre die die deutsche politik und
wirtschaft in peking an diesem tag
umgibt dabei will die mitreisende
wirtschaftsdelegation eigentlich vor
allem eins geschäfte mit china als
handelspartner machen und wir gehen live
dorthin schokotaler banerjee ist mit der
kanzlerin in peking show guten abend
kann denn so ein spagat funktionieren
aus einsatz für die demokratiebewegung
in hongkong und einsatz für die deutsche
wirtschaft in china
ja das kann dann funktionieren wenn die
interessen auf beiden seiten groß genug
sind und wir haben es ja gerade gehört
es stehen schon landwirtschaftliche
wirtschaft handfeste wirtschaftliche
interessen dahinter die kanzlerin ist
hier mit einer sehr hochkarätigen
wirtschaftsdelegation angereist
deutschland ist sowieso schon mit mehr
als 5200 unternehmen in china tätig und
hatte hier noch mal zusätzlich elf
weitere wirtschafts vereinbarungen heute
unterzeichnet und auch auf chinesischer
seite ist das interesse am handel mit
deutschland weiterhin ungebrochen groß
man hat hier noch einmal bekräftigt dass
man ein investitionsschutzabkommen gerne
bis nächstes jahr abgeschlossen haben
möchte dass dann weitere geschäft
weiteren geschäften den weg bahnen
könnte also unterm strich kann man sagen
wissen beide seiten dass sie gemeinsam
besser wegkommen als wenn sie sich
zerstreiten vor allem vor dem
hintergrund des handels konfliktes mit
den usa also in schwierigen
weltpolitischen zeiten und das weiß
angela merkel darauf hat sie hier
vermutlich gesetzt als sie ihre kritik
geäußert hat sie hat vermutlich gedacht
moderate kritik so wie sie sie
vorgetragen hat wird diese deutsch
chinesische beziehungen durchaus noch
aushalten
die analyse aus peking von giacomo della
bella die vielen dank unser nächstes
thema als der diesel skandal nicht mehr
zu leugnen war versprachen deutschlands
große autobauer reumütig sich von nun an
ehrlich zu machen
die betrogenen autofahrer
hunderttausende bekamen software-updates
die sollten den viel zu hohen
schadstoffausstoß ihrer diesel
wenigstens etwas verringern
und jetzt steht die frage im raum ob
alles nur gelogen war mehrere gerichte
stufen die software updates als
unzulässige abschalt einrichtungen ein
mit ihnen so messungen der deutschen
umwelthilfe sind die dieselmotoren
teilweise noch schmutziger als vorher
axel konrad mein diesel ist jetzt sauber
dachte lothar sg nachdem er bei seinem
vw tiguan ein software update
durchführen ließ kein schlechtes
gewissen wegen der abgase keine angst
vor fahrverboten mehr
ich habe ja dann
nach diesem software abgeht geglaubt
dass dieses fahrzeug so sauber ist dass
es nicht mehr von den fahrverboten
betroffen ist
das hat sich weiter näher geben und das
war eine große enttäuschung dass dieses
nicht der fall ist
die deutsche umwelthilfe hat
nachgemessen verschiedene hersteller
verschiedene typen alles diese nach
einer software nachrüstung die
ergebnisse ernüchternd bis erschreckend
die fahrzeuge sind im einzelfall sogar
schmutziger als zuvor wir haben
nachgemessen und festgestellt dass die
stickoxid-emissionen im winter häufig
sogar noch höher liegen als im sommer
vor dem update bei den nachgebesserten
fahrzeugen greift die abgasreinigung
nämlich nur bei bestimmten temperaturen
bei vw zwischen 15 und 33 grad ist es
kälter oder wärmer wird die
abgasreinigung heruntergefahren
die hersteller sprechen hier von thermo
fenster abgesegnet wurde das vom
zuständigen ministerium und vom
kraftfahrtbundesamt dem kba ich denke
ein großes manko an dieser vorschrift
system das man es nicht definiert hat
dass man keine konkreten unteren und
oberen werte definiert hat und insofern
oblag ist den automobilherstellern in
zusammenarbeit mit dieser behörde
nämlich das kba europlatz diesen beiden
institutionen sozusagen das selber zu
definieren
keine stellungnahme vom
verkehrsministerium daimler antwortet
und schreibt von einer zulässigen so
wörtlich emissionsminderung strategie
darüber streiten experten und gerichte
lothar es kann klagte auf rücknahme
seines fahrzeuges und bekam in erster
instanz recht
wir haben mittlerweile etliche
entscheidungen bekommen dass eben dieses
sogenannte thermo fenster illegal ist
das ist nicht meine abschnitt
einrichtung handelt für diese einer
ausnahmetatbestand gelten muss diese
ausnahmetatbestand aber nicht erfüllt
auch vier jahre nach bekanntwerden des
abhörskandals geht die trickserei weiter
und beschäftigt wie der autofahrer und
gerichte die csu will voll auf das thema
umwelt setzen bayern soll schon deutlich
vor allen anderen bundesländern und
damit vor 2050 klimaneutral werden
das steht in einem strategiepapier der
partei dass die gerade laufende
vorstandsklausur beschließen soll
ministerpräsident markus söder will den
kauf energieeffizienter haushaltsgeräte
steuerlich fördern und es soll anreize
geben alte heizungsanlagen und gebäude
zu modernisieren und wir bleiben noch
moment beim thema umwelt
bundesumweltministerin svenja schulze
spd die plastiktüten endgültig verbieten
doch wie viele gibt es überhaupt noch in
deutschland hier ist die antwort 2015
waren es noch 5,6 milliarden
aber dann wurden es jedes jahr weniger
hauptgrund der handel hat sich
freiwillig verpflichtet keine
plastiktüten mehr kostenlos
herauszugeben
umgerechnet heißt dass jeder deutsche
hat vor ein paar jahren noch 68 tüten im
jahr genutzt und jetzt nur noch 24
trotzdem soll jetzt ein verbot kommen
mehr von venedig so stellt sich svenja
schulze die zukunft vor
wenn jeder trägt zum einkauf immer einen
solchen beuteln mit sich
umweltfreundlich und recyclingfähig ich
habe heute das verbot von plastiktüten
auf den weg gebracht weil es mir
wirklich ernst ist mit dem ausstieg aus
dieser wegwerfmentalität dinge nur ein
paar minuten zu benutzen und sie einfach
dann wegzuwerfen so geht das nicht
weiter
verboten werden sollen plastiktüten die
eine gewisse wandstärke also dicke haben
diese tüten vom wochenmarkt zum beispiel
dürften nicht mehr herausgegeben werden
wie es jetzt noch häufig der fall ist
also ich benötige irgendwer proma
klüpfel etwas die typen auch mit diesen
plastiktüten im supermarkt soll schluss
sein
seit 2016 zeit der kunde für die tüte
eine freiwillige selbstverpflichtung die
der handel eingegangen war und seines
erachtens auch gut funktioniert wir
haben über zwei drittel weniger
plastiktüten in deutschland sind damit
das einzige land in europa das jetzt
schon die vorgaben auf europäischer
ebene über erfüllt und es ist noch nicht
das ende viele weitere unternehmen
verzichten momentan sogar ganz auf
kunststofftüten und insofern sind wir
natürlich von dieser entscheidung
enttäuscht
diese dünnen beutel für obst und gemüse
so genannte hemdchen leute sollen nicht
verboten werden umweltschützer fürchten
dass der kunde auch sie ausreicht dort
haben wir immerhin noch einen verbrauch
von 37 tüten pro kopf was viel zu viel
ist
oder andere kaufen sich dann hin und
wieder doch diese mehr wie ich taschen
die eigentlich dafür ausgelegt sind ja
sie tatsächlich mehrmals zu benutzen und
oft stapeln sich inhalt diese taschen im
haushalt der anteil von plastiktüten am
gesamt verpackungsmüll ist rechnerisch
klein das geplante verbot ist also eher
symbolischer natur
die bildung einer neuen regierung in
brandenburg nach der wahl dürfte noch
schwieriger werden als ohnehin schon
der bisherige landeschef der cdu ingo
senftleben will von allen ämtern
zurücktreten hintergrund ist ein
machtkampf in seiner partei er verlässt
damit auch die sondierungsgespräche über
eine neue regierung mit spd und grünen
die grünen sagen sollte sich in
brandenburgs cdu jetzt der rechts
konservative flügel durchsetzen sei
keine koalition mit der cdu mehr denkbar
die zahlen des statistischen bundesamtes
lassen erst einmal aufhorchen immer mehr
kinder werden in deutschland
vernachlässigt missbraucht körperlich
und psychisch misshandelt
für 2018 meldet die behörde einen
höchststand bei rund 50.000 400
minderjährigen wurde festgestellt dass
sie in gefahr sind
das sind 10 prozent mehr fälle als 2017
zu ihrem schutz wurden 7.800 kinder von
den jugendämtern vorläufig in obhut
genommen
das familienministerium sagt dazu ein
grund für die gestiegenen zahlen sei die
veränderte und verbesserte arbeitsweise
in den jugendämtern auch die bevölkerung
sei sensibler geworden und schaue
genauer hin
im machtkampf um den dreck cit hat der
britische regierungschef boris johnson
wieder eine niederlage eingefahren hat
britische oberhaus hat das gesetz
verabschiedet das einen ungeregelten
eu-austritt verhindern soll
nun will johnson am montag wieder
versuchen raschen neuwahlen
durchzusetzen
auch bei dieser abstimmung dürfte er an
der opposition scheitern
die istanbuler vorsitzende der größten
oppositionspartei chp in der türkei ist
zu fast zehn jahren haft verurteilt
worden
die richter sprachen in jinan kaftan
gigolo unter anderem der terror
propaganda und präsidenten beleidigung
schuldig die anklage stützte sich
wesentlich auf twitter nachrichten der
politikerin
die chp will gegen das urteil vorgehen
und halte mit während des
berufungsverfahrens bleibe kraft angelo
auf freiem fuß seit tagen banken die
menschen im osten der usa nun schon wie
heftig hurrikan dorian bei ihnen wütend
wird jetzt ist der sturm in north
carolina auf land getroffen
den menschen bis hinauf nach new york
steht zwar ein ungemütliches wochenende
bevor aber es scheint klar so verheerend
wie auf den bahamas wird es bei weitem
nicht dort auf den bahamas ist überall
spürbar wie dorian vielen menschen ihre
lebensgrundlage zerstört hat elmar
theveßen berichtet bill berry wusste
nicht ob seine frau turner noch leben
würde
reines glück eine naturgewalt zu
überstehen die gegenstände in geschosse
verwandelte häuser zerlegte nicht viel
ist übrig von dem ort an dem schüler mit
anderen ausharrte das kracht ein brausen
und dann flogen dinge hier durch die
wand viele menschen auf diesem teil von
abaco island sind traumatisiert von
diesem hurrikan der kategorie 4
das lässt sich nicht mit einer kategorie
beschreiben es war wie eine atombomben
irgendwo zwischen all den trümmern auf
den bahamas finden die retter immer
wieder tote die behörden befürchten dass
bis zu 1000 menschen ihr leben verloren
zehntausende verloren ihr zuhause
hilfsgüter treffen ein vor allem aus den
vereinigten staaten die weitgehend
verschont wurden von der
zerstörungskraft des hurricans dorian
ging heute in north carolina mit
windgeschwindigkeiten von 140
stundenkilometern an land auf den
vorgelagerten inseln wie opfer cook
werden heftige schäden erwartet bei
weitem aber nicht so verheerend wie die
fast flächendeckende zerstörung hier auf
den bahamas fast drei meter hoch steht
das wasser in meinem haus betet für uns
bleibt stark bahamas und dann geht er
mit seiner zehnjährigen tochter grace in
eine ungewisse zukunft
unfassbare bilder von den bahamas robert
mugabe war einer der bekanntesten und
umstrittensten staatschefs in afrika er
ist heute gestorben im alter von 95
jahren
fast vier jahrzehnte lang war er
präsident von simbabwe erst
freiheitskämpfer dann diktator bekannt
für exzentrik und größenwahn auf einer
wahlkampfveranstaltung hat einmal gesagt
nur gott der mich ernannt hat wird mich
abwählen können sondert heißt zeigt was
mugabe für sein land bedeutete und
welches erbe er hinterlässt er war macht
verliebt und skrupellos robert mugabe 37
jahre lang herrschte er über simbabwe
bis ihn das militär 2017 aus dem amt
drängte man hat mir gesagt wenn du nicht
zurücktritt wird es ein blutvergiessen
geben
mugabe endete als diktator dabei war
einst ein volksheld
er führte die schwarze mehrheit an die
macht 1980 wird aus der britischen
kronkolonie rhodesien das unabhängige
simbabwe
doch im lauf der zeit wird mugabe immer
autokratischer und korrupter seine
gegner lässt denn niederknüppeln und
ermorden tausende weisse farmer
enteignen und vertreiben so
wirtschaftete mugabe die einstige
kornkammer des kontinents herunter und
war doch bis zuletzt von sich überzeugt
ob ich das land ruiniert habe nein
natürlich nicht verglichen mit anderen
afrikanischen ländern herrscht hier
wohlstand sein volk feierte seiner
entmachtung als befreiung doch der
erhoffte aufschwung blieb aus unter
mugabes nachfolger emmerson mnangagwa
hat sich die lage noch verschlechtert es
herrscht hyperinflation es fehlt an
lebensmitteln benzin und strom gibt es
meistens nicht
und auch mit demonstranten geht das neue
regime nicht anders um
man begegnet ihnen mit verboten und
gewalt jetzt ein schnitt was ganz
anderes in dieser sendung jetzt gucken
wir uns an was die technik als nächstes
wunderding anpreist in berlin ist ab
heute wieder offside
die technikmesse war mal als große
deutsche funkausstellung gestartet
mittlerweile geht es längst nicht mehr
nur am fernseher oder haushaltsgeräte
sondern ganz neuem faltbares smartphones
die jetzt marktreif sind um ihre
bildschirme und um künstliche
intelligenz da schenkt der roboter auch
schon mal das getränk ein den überblick
gibt hans jürgen thiel fernsehzukunft
auf der ifa diese flexiblen bildschirme
lassen sich ein und ausrollen während
andere durchsichtig zur glasscheibe
mutieren prototypen die zeigen was
möglich ist
der käufer muss ich diesmal mit eher
versteckten innovationen begnügen
künstliche intelligenz etwa abgekürzt ki
oder englisch künstlicher intelligenz
wird ein schwerpunkt hier auf dieser ifa
sein denn immer mehr geräte sind mit
künstlicher intelligenz ausgestattet und
dann künstlicher intelligenz lernen die
geräte ihre anwendungsmöglichkeiten zu
verbessern und das selbst in der küche
so gleicht dieser backofen
sauerstoffgehalt und temperatur mit
lernenden online datenbanken ab regelt
garzeiten
automatisch in fernsehern soll die
herkömmliche tv bilder für 8-k pixel
riesen aufbereiten verkaufsargument
solange inhalte in dieser auflösung noch
mangelware sind
ich würde es eher so unter
marketinggesichtspunkten sehen das
verkauft sich halt leute sowas ist das
tolles da sollte man aber nicht zuviel
achtung vorhaben das ist eine reine
auswertung von daten und die ist
meistens noch nicht mal besonders
intelligent offenbar nötiges marketing
denn die branchenumsätze bröckeln von
12,6 milliarden euro in 2012 auf
geschätzte 8,6 in diesem jahr rückgänge
gerade bei tv geräten für die kunden
immer weniger bezahlen durchschnittlich
564 euro waren es zuletzt zu gelten
smartphones jetzt als innovations-
bringe die längst auch höhere umsätze
erzielen und nach anfänglichen knick
problemen sollen faltbare smartphone
displays jetzt marktreif sein so dass
auch faltbar hier jetzt kommt natürlich
die intelligenz beim sport darunter ein
fußball klassiker bitteschön deutschland
gegen die niederlande gut 90 minuten
anpfiff in hamburg joachim löws team in
der em quali noch ungeschlagen drei
spiele drei siege
oranje dagegen mit nur drei punkten nach
zwei partien jetzt schon unter druck und
will gegen den erz rivalen unbedingt
gewinnen
es steht viel auf dem spiel für trainer
kuhmann und sein team
große hoffnungen ruhen auf kapitän und
abwehrchef virtual van dyk der gerade
erst zu europas fußballer des jahres
gewählt wurde
der champions league sieger vom fc
liverpool will revanche für die
hinspielpleite in amsterdam
sr image von deutschland hat einen guten
mix aus erfahrung und talent aber wir
wollen gewinnen und werden versuchen den
deutschen weg zu tun van dyk für viele
der beste verteidiger der welt könnte
zum größten problem der deutschen
auswahl werden doch sollte orange
verlieren gerät sogar die qualifikation
für die euro in gefahr
und jetzt zu einem deutlich kleineren
ball und da ist auch eine deutsche
nationalmannschaft auf erfolgskurs
nämlich die der tischtennis herren bei
der em in ort gewinnt das deutsche team
mit europameister timo boll souverän
gegen slowenien mit 3 zu 0 und steht
jetzt im halbfinale auftakterfolg beim
großen preis von italien monster für
ferrari sebastian vettel fuhr im freien
training hinter mercedes pilot lewis
hamilton auf platz 3 schnellster war
vettels teamkollege charlie klar es
läuft bei schale claire vergangenes
wochenende der erste saisonsieg für
ferrari nun schon wieder auf 1 der
21-jährige hat das auto derzeit bestens
im griff wesentlich besser als
teamkollege vettel der probleme mit der
abstimmung hat seinen status als nummer
eins bei ferrari sieht er durch erklären
nicht gefährdet ich denke es ist am
wichtigsten dass wir zusammenarbeiten
und nicht gegeneinander
das scheint zu funktionieren alles
andere wäre ja auch energieverschwendung
seit neun jahren warten die ferrari fans
auf einen heimsieg der roten schade klar
scheint in der verfassung zu sein die
erfolglose zeit beenden zu können was
was von mir denken was passiert wenn
sich fußball kunst und natur begegnen
das können wir jetzt zeigen dass hier
ist das wörthersee stadion in klagenfurt
statt fußballer warten hier 200 bäume
auf zuschauer für den wald heißt die
aktion mehrere jahre bereitete ein
schweizer künstler das alles vor das
heimspiel von birke eiche und co dauert
noch bis ende oktober
dann übernehmen wieder die
fußballspieler bleibt bei uns noch der
blick aufs wetter da hat katja horne
vergleich eher herbstlich kühle
aussichten heute journal mit der
kollegin marietta slomka heute um 22 uhr
wir sind auch am wochenende für sie da
und zwar sehr gerne sehen uns morgen
wieder
in allen einen angenehmen abend meine
damen und herren
letzte nacht gab es im sauerland
bodenfrost das lag einfach daran dass da
keine wolken etwas warm halten konnten
und einen klaren streifen gab es auch
heute über tag sehr viel sonne also
zwischen dem saarland und mecklenburg
vorpommern
derweil es am alpenrand dichte wolken
mit regen und opfer nordwesten kamen
dichtere wolken heran und die ziehen
jetzt in den nächsten 24 stunden weiter
nach osten das bedeutet für uns doch
meist einen stark bewölkt bis bedeckt
samstag und auch immer wieder regen
heute nachträgen des haben allgäu bis
zum bayerischen wald und auch zwischen
dem sauerland und sylt sonst ist es zum
teil auch trocken es wird aber nicht
mehr so kalt wie in der vergangenen
nacht das verdanken wir den wolken bei
13 bis 6 grad morgen liegen dann die
höchsttemperaturen am alpenrand und in
niederbayern bei 12 bis 14
sonst bei 16 bis 19 uhr und in berlin
steigen die werte auf 20 bis 22 grad das
ist genau die region muss morgen auch
noch am meisten sonnenschein gibt
nämlich hier nordöstlich der elbe
zwischen sylt und dem niederrhein
dagegen jetzt kräftige schauer zum teil
auch gewitter bei einem zum teil böigem
wind aus westlichen richtungen
in süddeutschland tut sich die sonne
morgen wirklich schwerer ist es meist
bedeckt immer wieder fällt regen können
auch einzelne gewitter dabei sein
sehr wechselhaft wird dann auch der
sonntag oder freundlichsten wird es dann
noch an der nordseeküste oder auch im
emsland sein
bei höchsttemperaturen zwischen 12 und
19 grad und in der neuen woche wird es
dann von tag zu tag ein bisschen
sonniger trockener und wärmer und das
zeigt sich auch beim temperaturen trend
für berlin
ende nächster woche könnten sogar wieder
über 22 grad erreicht werden schönen
abend noch